to brothers and sisters and dear
friends. For those who have children
like myself, I've got three daughters
and for those who have kids or who are
going to have children, brothers and
sisters, sometimes we think that what we
consume is what we eat or what we smell
or what we hear. We don't really think
about what we see. And that's why the
scholars say the heart doesn't desire
what the eyes don't see. Brothers and
sisters, Jurio, alhamdulillah, is a new
platform inshallah for kids, for Muslim
kids. Yes, any kids for that matter of
course, whoever wants to watch.
Alhamdulillah with Muslim Islamic
values.
>> Sweetheart, I'm sorry for letting you
wait. Uh, is everything all right? What
are you watching? Ya Allah, isn't there
any secure platform for my baby I can
trust? Did I hear secure platform? Say
no more, ma'am. Allow me to introduce
you to Juria Plus, an actual secure
platform for your kid from the makers of
Omar and Hannah. Unlike YouTube Kids,
for example, Curio Plus offers safe
content without you having to worry
about your child coming across any
inappropriate videos. You can find
Islamic, educational, fun, and engaging
videos without advertisements. All
videos are 100% filtered for children.
If you search for Daka, you can even
find my videos there, too. There is even
an extra section for teaching the Quran
in a fun way. To prevent your child from
spending hours in front of the screen,
there is a filter function that allows
you to monitor the times. And do you
know what caught my eye in particular?
Dur Plus puts a 15-second timer between
every three short videos so children
don't get addicted to continuous
scrolling. I think it's a very
thoughtful detail. Especially nowadays,
parents need to pay attention to what
their children consume. It is therefore
very important to choose apps carefully.
comment case or check out the link in my
bio to start a 7-day free trial of Dur
Plus for your child having a secure time
in front of the screen.
>> And brothers and sisters, I have that
fear when my kids are watching
something. I'm monitoring them closely.
When I'm not in the house, I tell my
wife to monitor them closely. When
they're watching YouTube, whatever it is
for that matter, we have to be extra
extra careful cuz why, brothers and
sisters? What we see with our eyes can
destroy our hearts. And from a young age
when our children are absorbing just
look at these videos I'm going to show
you guys of Mickey Mouse or whatever it
is for that matter Tom and Jerry and
look at the in look at the indirect look
forget indirect it's direct in your face
now and this is so concerning for every
single parent and now finally there is a
solution dur brothers and sisters where
you can inshallah get it on your laptop
whatever you want to put in brothers and
sisters on your phone and get involve
brothers and sisters they have a 60%
discount before that guys look at these
videos. The dangers that our children
are facing.
>> I live with my mommy and my other mommy.
>> I'm gay. I'm trans. Norma,
>> I like girls. I'm bisexual.
[Music]
>> Your children are not just watching
cartoons. They are being programmed.
From violence being normalized to LGBTQ
messages hidden in plain sight to occult
imagery and dark humor, mainstream
cartoons today are feeding your child's
mind with agendas you never approved of.
You are careful about what they eat, but
are you careful about what they watch?
Because while you are distracted,
they're learning values that go against
your beliefs. This is why we bring you
an alternative, Durio Plus, which is a
safe Islamic streaming app. It offers
fun cartoons, Quranic recitations, and
turbia lessons. All designed to build
your child's iman in a clean halal
environment. You can even choose Vocus
only content, no music, no hidden
messages, just pure Islamic learning.
Download Durio Plus today and give your
kids the gift of IM. So what you just
saw there brothers and sisters is a
reality of what's going on on the ground
inshallah and your kids are going to
what does that mean? What does that word
mean? You know subhan allah. So guys, if
you are watching this, I urge you guys
inshallah to download durio. Use their
60% discount in they are giving with my
uh discount code inshallah brothers and
sisters and protect your children
because they are our
future brothers and sisters that the
prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said when the son of Adam dies
all of his deeds come to an end except
an ongoing and one of those things are
what brothers and sisters a righteous
child that makes dua for you. If our
children go astray they are not a
saddakar for us. We want them to be
Muslims. We want them to live on to and
we want them to die on tohed and every
action they do is a for us and it is our
duty and Allah will question us
specifically the men. Allah will
question you about your family. So
brothers and sisters if you're watching
this inshallah download the app and
protect your children's mind, their
soul. Subhan Allah. Even their body
subhan Allah brothers and sisters with
what they watch what they hear brothers
and sisters not just with what they eat.
So guys, inshallah please please I urge
you guys to download Duro. Inshallah an
amazing amazing platform. I want to
thank the people behind it.
Alhamdulillah. May Allah bless and
preserve them that they have this
platform that I can now make sure that
my kids have a safe place where they can
watch whichever cartoon they want
without it starting off with something
innocent and then go into something
else. Download the app on May Allah
bless and preserve you guys inshallah.
I'm a father and I'm sure there's many
fathers and mothers watching this. and
share with your friends and family.